hey everyone here welcome back to yet
another episode of watching the Watchmen
today we're not talking about Watchmen
we're to went Doomsday Clock Geoff Johns
Gary Frank Brad Anderson is the colorist
as well but he's not of John Higgins
caliber no one is of their predecessors
of caliber this is issue six nothing has
really happened in the story death
what's up man I'm good Tom um that was a
bit that caught me I've gotta get there
Tom I'm still getting my stuff in or I'm
still I'm still downloading the book
from the internet you know what I mean
for free yeah shout out you have read
comic online dot T oh that's the one I
normally use and always always were open
to how how comprehensive it was but yeah
um we're never gonna get a deal with DC
Owen we've slugged the CEO off too much
and now we run saying pirate comics yeah
[ __ ] hell Tom they're gonna be human
I know I know and but I'm annoyed as
well because I can't help but feel we're
gonna get into the whole issue as a
whole but sort of wasting our time a
little bit like a lot I've been reading
a lot of reviews just for winning their
what people are thinking everyone's
pretty much in agreement the plot
literally didn't move an inch with this
issue yeah it's terrible um I don't know
how people are still on board with the
series to be honest because there are
people out there yeah but it's just
ridiculous really how how slow-paced it
is we are halfway through now yeah and
nothing's happened they are all no no I
mean you know a couple of people have
met you know I mean but you could have
covered that in an issue yeah yeah it
shouldn't be this long Tom it really
really shouldn't and if it's going at
this pace they're not gonna be able to
tell a compelling story in the in this
dozen so issues you know maybe should
have been a bit longer I the most
exciting thing for me like I recently
read seven Basterds volume four by Jason
Aaron and Jason the tour which is an OK
volume wasn't the best volume but I
enjoy it I could digest it in an
afternoon you know is it exciting thing
going issue by issue following the
narrative but there's no there's no Fred
here the momentum is just just not there
yeah don't you know what you mean Tom
and I'm not happy with it I've supposed
to get what you paid for don't yeah you
do you do and the the the front cover
itself deviates light from the norm
normally alan moore alec evans we get
you know the image panned in and then we
sort of realized where we are location
was but here is more of a sort of i
don't know it's almost like an omnibus
cover isn't it's just showing you a lot
of the characters yeah i do quite like
the cover though and you know i'm not a
stickler for continuity and so you know
if they can't do something well i enjoy
it and I do think this is done well but
you hate it don't you
I can already tell hey just I don't I
don't really know its relevance to the
issue because this scene isn't in the
issue I mean it's kind of cool to see
Ozzie sort of staring out from Archie
and then obviously the bat-signal below
and and the dust and all that sort of
idea but I guess it's not really iconic
it's almost like an old sixties cover
it's just kind of here's the characters
that we're gonna meet today even though
we don't meet most of them because it's
for the most part an origin story and
fair to say a fairly unnecessary one
really we didn't really need to know
this yeah now you're completely right
yeah just basically it is the mime and
marionettes origin story the two
characters that everyone wants to know
about and it opens up with marina as a
child watching her father getting beat
by a policeman for not giving them
protection money or something I don't
know it's not really clear it's kind of
the generic corrupt cops like exactly
yeah and women that kind of feel sorry
for this character but I never really
saw it as that tragic like it just
didn't feel that impactful to me because
I already knew how she turned out so I
didn't really have any sympathy for her
whereas if you tell the story in
chronological order with like say the
movie Chronicle and which is also about
like a super villain yeah you can really
get on the villains side and agree with
the dark way that they go and but where
this is like it's a bit difficult to
warm to someone that you already dislike
and when she you know she finds a father
at one point in the issue ironically
hanging next to his puppets and that
could be impactful but it just felt like
a bit sort of like I could see this
coming you know what I mean mm-hmm
rather than just a shot out of nowhere
and even with her father killing herself
it's really hard to agree with a dog
prophet they take it is I can't side
with two children killers yeah I can
kind of understand why they kill them
the empathy for that but yeah you don't
really see a good side of this girl and
that's not her fault or sona's then she
lives her in this construct but no I
completely agree it didn't this whole
thing didn't really endear me further to
the characters just distance me yeah
again yeah definitely and you know it's
all about choosing a dark path and
speaking of paths Tom you like our and
you weave this in we'll find the Joker
pushing Batman along a path yep don't we
you can tell the goal and materials
coming out now Tom with six issues deep
and I've saved all my best jokes till
now it's just the I mean strings and
fate and these sort of metaphors are so
played out like they're really really
like generic and uninteresting and it
kind of makes me cringe like the Jeff is
doing it I mean you've got to be
positive as well as negative I do kind
of like I might be saying I love it
when her father's thrown to the ground
you sort of see that that Grim Reaper
puppet sort of stared on over he sholde
aids you know it it's fine and the
moving back from from the doll and her
and the doll and her is Kannada and yet
again I do want to give props to Gary
Frank I think the guy can draw eyes very
well he can cano emotion brilliantly
it's yet a brilliantly drawn book um and
I do like how realistic and transitional
the origin story is alongside the dolls
so yeah credit words to you Gary Frank
does a great job with what he's given to
work with everything in the book is
really well drawn in other straighted
and it adds a touch of realism to him
but it's just the scenarios like I like
that you know the Joker's capture bat
and they have nice banter back and forth
but it's it's obvious that this is like
very roped joke is obviously a staple of
comics and some would argue is the
greatest villain of all time
and his inclusion in a Watchmen story
should really like elevate the book
massively but it doesn't it just feels
like oh well here's the Joker it feels
like a cameo and it doesn't really even
feel that necessary to be honest the
Joker does very little in this issue and
it's just a shame that the supporting
cast is with and this scenario of being
with it I finally caught Batman it's
been done to death
yeah and in something like Watchmen you
expect better you do you do Trudy laughs
is the title which kind of caught me off
guard I like this little clip nature of
that and then when we get to the quote
there's a certain you know pay for state
generates but yeah you're completely
right this is a huge deal that we're
getting a lot of joke here he's not just
being introduced at the end of the issue
he's carrying a lot of the story and
what did you think of this little
encounter with the mr. Freeze's
underlings in the tunnel yeah quite like
it's a nice little comedic thing how
they're swapping gangs and stuff but
yeah it just feels very roped and
predictable to me and it's just these
nut that's the thing with this book it
has nice moments let it throughout it
but it's like the sum of its parts are
better than the whole basically it's
nice little tidbit but overall it's the
story itself nothing write home about no
and it's like in Moore's hand hear me
describing the nerve toxin as relaxer
bat I don't know if there's a pond I'm
not getting there or if there's a tox
you know what I mean if there's some
sort of yeah medicine that he's putting
up but I bet he's not whereas if it was
more I'd have to dig deeper and I'm sure
he would be like we've all we are
mentions loads on the show but in
Killing Joke
when Joker paralyzes Barbara Barbara
Gordon it's all like book puns and like
the spine on the coffee table and like
it's a die it's just so good or as yeah
I'd relax a bat I don't I don't really
know and then I think if we met the guy
before joke has this like tattoo are it
in house yeah he must just be doing his
tattoo you must have done those terrible
ones in Suicide Squad the aegis he's
just hanging around I'm just drawn
Stefani looks quite quick beat I'm more
interested in him then I am the mime and
marionette yeah it's kind of cool did
you Marc Maron might be in the new Joker
film oh no I didn't actually
yeah which is kind of interesting I mean
I actually listened to a lot of Marc
Maron's podcasts and you were a big
superior guy Marc Maron is famously like
anti superhero and his latest episode
with Paul Rudd has became quite
notorious because he like rags on
ant-man loads and very sort of awkwardly
like oh yeah okay so yeah you should
listen to E and and all about all of our
double finger listeners I should listen
to it as well and well we have the ring
ring the bell juxtaposition where it's
marionettes hands are up and then the
marionettes hands are up and that her
father being a puppet shop owner this
whole can see what your thoughts on this
yeah it's a bit weird innit but you know
I mean there's been worse superhero
origins I suppose at least she wasn't
bitten by a radioactive prophet exactly
you know I mean but yeah it's just I
don't really care oh yeah it's not like
she was a she wasn't obsessed over it or
anything it's just you know I mean it's
just a bit weird that this thing that's
like you don't have to your origin story
when what hero you choose to be doesn't
have to tie into your childhood like
Superman he got his thing from Krypton
didn't eat fair enough
Batman fell in the cave about hmm you
decide to become Batman marionette i dad
made a puppet so she decided become that
I just don't like yga I pop it over
everything else yeah yes don't like it
why not choose the Richard Nixon puppet
Tom yeah yeah that's true actually and I
that would be sick that because some
maybe you know all those bank-robbers
that where Richard Nixon masters maybe
their father had a Richard Nixon puppet
I've just blown the conspiracy open she
mentions so basically that her dad's
asking what you want me to make for you
engines and Bonnie which I had to look
up didn't know who the hell up see says
a pirate and this is clearly a black
Freya solve reference and Bonnie was a
real person actually from the late
sixteen hundreds an Irish pirate
operating in the Caribbean one of the
most famous female pirates of all time
so I'm not there that's kinda
interesting he mentions Cleopatra the
ruler of Egypt so we get those Ozzie
sort of ideas as well and it's the
classic thing it's the you know these
these star-crossed lovers were smitten
as kids
and came across their own path and he's
bored in their shop and she's bored over
across the street and this quit there's
some nice physical movements that I
won't deny are quite like I quite like
when she puts on the little minimal show
and then sort of reveals herself behind
and him gone it's it's in these wordless
captions where Gary Frank and just
flourished I think the book is its best
yeah definitely like there is talent
here in the art it's just even geoff
johns i don't know what he was doing
during this because he is a good writer
normally but it's just mmm
I just marionette have superpowers
because she's got strong string that's
like a power but you know pulls some
guy's head off with these yeah I just
don't know like yeah I do quite like
this fight scene like when it gets
really gory in this book it's it's good
but and it's nice how Joker's shooting
his own men for laughs like it's just
yeah that's some of its part it's not in
service of the story it's just cool
action moments yes if you were to say
what is this actually doing for this
story it's it's nothing no no just a
little action set piece no that's what's
so good about Watchmen there's not that
many big set pieces until we get to the
end but that every panel it feels like
is pushing us forward in some direction
or fleshing out a character or
references something queries this isn't
really happening here and a lot of the
dialogue I think is very 10 but when she
brings Marcus and I know the shop leaves
a lot of people speeches the first time
they see any just a bit cream G really I
don't
I like gazing at the puppets I'm looking
at the bottom of page five where we can
see like a new base I think like the god
of death
Fairey their chaplain over his shoulder
so you know her dad was clearly a very a
marionette maker on earth there's a name
for that but yeah we go back put a smile
in the face obviously mine is completely
it could be stone face there and we get
into the fight scene like you say which
again is quite interesting it's hyper
violent I was kind of taken aback this
and like when they're kids as well it's
really brutal yeah it is and that's
probably one of the books strongest
points that kind of hammers home that it
is a very realistic telling and it's
very great I say realistic it's grounded
and it's real it's like Robocop it's it
is hyper violence I've contradicted
myself so much in that sentence there
but so it's a grounded realistic hyper
violent fight scene you know I mean it's
mundane she's what she's walking along
the street wearing a little winter coat
three people pop up in their little
winter coats and then BOOM a type of
violent so it's a realistic scenario
that devolves into some crazy
off-the-wall thing and but yet [ __ ] you
don't really do when you made you got
bring in the head off just just the last
minute so in the back of my head I was
like no no doesn't she take the head off
with the wire but no you're right she
literally tears this guy's head off
that's got no precedent yeah
don't understand how it happens and it's
just like you get superpowers all of a
sudden think you've got to be like a
Wonder Woman level the heroic to do that
to pull something yeah clean off like
yes yeah you can't even cut someone's
head clean off tom you've got to get it
a couple of times with an axe
trust me I know um yeah so it's very
weird like that this is meant to be an
origin story but bah
like two months of their childhood it
actually does very little doesn't like
how they have their powers why they have
them it just explains why she's got a
costume yeah yeah exactly and she's
always had this sort of angle late and
that that you know made it made more
Parton and when she's walking out with a
marionette there she gets cornered by
generic bullies and it's kind of
referencing the scene before I guess
where the heads being pulled off
and again you know I want to give
plaudits to Frank I think when she's
being thrown to the ground when she's
been he's just kind of I don't know I
don't know if it's quite just what he
doesn't hit me anywhere in the heart
strings when I look at it he doesn't
move me in a way similar to like when
you see Rorschach as a child
encountering his mother you know that's
that's a really interesting scene and I
do kinda like like the juxtaposition
there we go of the the marionette in her
head and stuff like that but all in all
you kinda know what you're getting don't
you as the bullies descend then I even
kind of see the strings as it were yeah
exactly and it's just like very cliche
she was bullied at school Tom did you
see the Shazam and Aquaman trailers I
didn't actually know I need to catch up
on those well both of them had he was
bullied at school things a little school
of fish the bully Aquaman no he was
hanging out with the fish and that's
what he got bullied for Tom I'm like hey
little fish [ __ ] why don't you suck get
that fish to suck your dick I've seen it
on the Internet that's what they were
saying Tom right because you have you
seen that video on the Internet of a
fish sucking someone off yeah it was on
Facebook Tom you know I mean to put
anything on Facebook these days okay
it's not very nice Tom I was well I was
watching this documentary about Facebook
the other week and they literally just
let anything go on there as long as it's
viral
they don't care anymore Tom stick to
Twitter but anyway we went off-track
there that's how crap this book is Tom
it can't even keep you engaged when you
taking the piss out of a fish and she's
Amish Sam was bullied as well yeah well
Shazam is a kid and he was bullied as
well okay so yeah but still of lots of
diversity and the origin stories of DC
right there how are the trailers in
general I'll watch him after this I
thought they were really disappointing
like really not just the DC actually
Aquaman had quite a good trailer um but
Shazam I don't know everyone's up in
arms about it saying it's amazing but I
didn't think it was anything crazy and
Godzilla I thought was pretty mad she's
a mess all the calm because the only
thing I saw was the castle rock but
that's alright because like I worship
Marc
been on d night and i just want to see
him do well like yeah well they were
pretty crap tom so I wouldn't waste my
time with them Godzilla was rubbish
Marvel weren't there
they don't Marvel have got at the point
now where they don't even need to go to
comic-con anymore because anyone right
yeah they just do that just like our sod
this full of gimp's full of people who
probably read Doomsday Clock and do
podcasts about it so they're not going
there
have you seen the venom trailer Tom why
long yeah I'm watch the able share the
line eater yeah surround my seed
terrible terrible trailer alright lots
of people are saying it's really good
but are just watching our mutual friend
it's Limehouse TV I think enjoyed it but
I don't know what he's watching Tom to
be fair that that guy did say that he
loved DC and well it's talking about
Marvel movies so I just don't know if
you know I'd like to know what fear for
Doomsday Clock actually no I I don't
know you've probably beat us up so I
don't want it he probably loves a
dangerous toy loving man you know any
slugs or Funko pops Tom ya know I saw
that this meeting which again has
someone who just likes the details who
likes the history it was cool and I'm
not gonna lie I was reading this like an
hour ago and my girlfriend was reading
behind me and I'd gasp she's like wow
the court of owls and I like seeing the
court of owls in the train station yeah
it's nice and I've got completely rain
on your parade Tom there's actually a
book called forever evil right in which
it was done a shitload better and
basically the new 52 had a massive arc
where the Justice League like the first
four volumes of it there were beating
the [ __ ] out of everyone the way I've
know right laughs you know Batman was
punching people and he loves that and
then like roundabouts issue three they
get this new member join an atomic arrow
summit basically it's that atom but it's
a woman anyway turns out she's she's
just an insider for another gang
so she shrinks down puts the sliver of
kryptonite in Superman's head and
basically she sets up all the pieces you
don't realize it's happening but she
sets of all the pieces so that the
Justice League can just be wiped out and
then the injustice league or is it it's
the crime syndicate sorry Tom avoided a
few YouTube comments they're not please
write them if you're gonna write them
because we need them but yet anyway the
crime syndicate stepped forward and they
just beat the crap out of the Justice
League they're basically the Justice
League from Earth 2 or 3 it might be in
the new 52 continuity anyway they're
from a different earth and not all evil
Tom and they beat the crap out of the
Justice League and they unite all the
villains on the planet and there's an
absolutely incredible double page spread
of all the DC villains gathered together
and at this meeting and this is just
like a crap version of that yeah are the
Owls there yeah I was uh I was weren't
there sorry I don't think there were yet
another word there were about then yet
there have been invented
yeah that was because I was sort of
looking here and there and this I'm not
an expert
I think sinestro's they're obviously
Riddler and scarecrow and various other
people that you know let us know in the
comments of you spy some people it's
quite cool played by Will Smith yeah
yeah we see two faced from the back
which is noises or DOOL DOOL suit there
but yeah this meeting again kind of okay
but it just feels like kind of wanky
fanservice like it's nice in a way to
see these source stuff but it's just
them saying no I disagree and no this is
my phone we're just treading water
narratively yeah exactly and you know
again it's just nothing's really
happening it's a cool set piece but do
you care
Khandaq is mentioned which is obviously
is a big big piece of the puzzle yeah
you you love that place don't you ever
since you've learned here well I didn't
realize or it was just a invention of
this but it's a kind of a DC geography
location right Black Adam lives there
mmm so glad they wrote it in because Tom
I'm not gonna lie if I read something
and it doesn't have a reference to
something every two pages I just
kill myself Tom I just died inside you
know I mean the need that in if for
something to be good I just need to be
filled to the brim with references even
if they don't mean anything or have any
consequence or wait and seeing contact
their Tom who amazing I don't know if
I'm reading too far into these
influences all these references I was
thinking why did he mention when we're
getting back into the flashback of
father talking about the marionette and
that she's gonna make knight or king
offer is that a reference maybe to
Camelot 3000 which is what Dave Gibbons
worked on which I think we discussed
with John Egan's briefly maybe it's not
I mean no it wasn't no no I'm sorry it
was Brian Bolland that we were talking
about regret and John Higgins but I mean
yeah maybe probably not and then we get
the cops coming in and intelligent for
the book oh it's like even though it's
not a just yeah I just comedy deal with
this to be honest review and it reminded
me a little bit of weary watch the
equalizer the Denzel film which is a
pretty sack of yeah it's pretty like
it's kind of crap but great light and
Denzel is always quality and like it's
like you know the cops that are like
doing that Mexican guy's mother's
restaurant and [ __ ] there are a mind of
e of these guys although they're better
written than these guys it's just it's
kind of a faceless evil that isn't very
compelling yeah I know what you mean
it's just the the stand-in guys isn't it
like you don't really I mean to be fair
you don't really need like a big bad
villain for this but it would have been
nice just to tie you back into Watchmen
somehow I think yeah like maybe one of
them killed their father and Rorschach
showed up just a second too late or
something you know I mean so she would
have liked this reason for going against
the the heroes of the world just a
little bit more depth through it would
have elevated it or even the cops that
in the investigating comedians murder in
the first issue yeah exactly that would
yeah that's a great show that would have
been much better but do they want to do
it no because it's probably not
referential enough to make people like
myself scream and go oh my god this is
the greatest book
because they mentioned something that I
know about yeah yeah there is just and
there's a lot of sort of uh you know
antagonism here for our scarecrows drawn
really well actually I like you saw an
old mouth beneath the the cowl but yeah
again pulling the cow off Batman
revealing his Troy density all these
things come into play and then we get
finally a home fried slice of Watchmen
in our mouths comedians there with the
sniper yeah which is it's a nice little
touch but of why I would have loved to
have seen the other side of this where
he was investigating it yeah they all
kind of came to a head at this location
and but it's just sort of a just shows
up and he shoots this terrible villain
who's been introduced in this issue and
then gets literally this bill and
typhoon it's been introduced just to be
killed
yeah yeah that's it lady right yet none
of the major villains get killed some
quarter bowels guy gets shot that's it
yeah well where and where has comedian
been all these years like it's been in
the DC Universe for for years and years
and years and all of a sudden he's just
showing up and killing costume villains
and where's he been where Tom I'm asking
like that's right oh yeah yeah III great
he's just he's been waiting for Geoff
Johns to write him in and it's just
clumsy and uninteresting and it's kind
of cool the you know the bullet pops
freeze his helmet and his underlings
call off the panel as well I kind of dig
that and really get shot in the in the
leg but but yeah and it's I I'm just
noticing actually seeing two of the guys
sort of morphing into the subway car at
the top of page 17 that's a kind of nice
little touch here but yeah all in all
joy and explosions happen we see that
huge woman engulfed where's Batman and
this is he kind of just left just kind
of you know be born
I don't know time probably you probably
get away with it but you know it wasn't
needed for this moment of the plot so
they just took him out any appear again
when he's needed
it's just bad right in his notes it is
bad writing not good and it's like we
mentioned or we didn't mention but I
want to mention the Incredibles to which
I know you weren't a fan of Ivor
and I thought was awful I really like
well I really like the first film and
one of the reasons I thought was all for
many many reasons is the first set piece
and the final set piece ended the same
way so the first set piece was the
Underminer going towards City Hall and
frozen he's basically slowing it down
slowing it down his ice and the final
set piece with screen slavers boat going
towards metropolis is Frozone slowed it
down slowed it down with ice and it's
just like that this is just lazy writing
Bradford and here we have lazy writing
again here we have the cops coming in
again marionette hiding under the desk
her hearing things are being bad sort of
puppet puns it's just like John's why
couldn't we move the action slightly
somewhere else why couldn't we've gone -
Ganga diner just just for the hell of it
yeah exactly
just a nice tie-in in the law that would
have been a bit more deep rather than
just like a name said you know I mean
we're just once something just a bit
more beyond what we've got and and it's
just yes I don't know what it is
speak you immigrant [ __ ] as well I feel
that's almost like a post Trump line
yeah there's no training in it Jack
likes modern social commentary interior
that was another thing about Watchmen my
watchman was written in the 80s and a
deconstructed politics in the 80s
whereas this is like set in the 80s but
deconstructed in modern politics which
is fine I mean you could it would
probably be relevant in the AES but it's
just a bit not just don't get a move on
with the plot please go on yeah yeah the
money's in night-owl which I don't know
if there's any SIM symbolism here again
it's just a bit of a tie-in isn't it
yeah I stopped my hat and mentioned a
little earlier I think I think we might
skipped over that when they she's
talking about making a something for or
something like that maybe that's of it
no no no it might be a little bit I
don't know idiots know that we've
literally missed it yeah yeah good and
there's this scene when they're sort of
you know embracing and again the
physicality of it is fantastic the
embrace is very believable and I suppose
Marcos origin is a mute isn't really is
it that you literally can't speak
English or I don't know it just doesn't
speak does he know that's a yeah I mean
you probably right it might be that but
yeah the blue
light as well as she sees her father
yeah again it's just don't know Tom I'm
just not that I'm like I'm like how we
see um Frank Sidebottom the the poppy of
that on the left of the panel that's
pretty cool yeah that's got a good
little spot as well but yeah it's just
very I mean you could have predicted all
this it didn't need to be 20 pages long
or whatever they could have just sped it
up even like little flashes of what the
origin story was like would have worked
better I think like she's seeing
something and then it just flashes up
for one panel like finding out a father
hanging up and instead of just giving it
like so much room when the story's just
so plodding along it just the pace is so
dull you've really read it I mean let's
consider you know one of the best issues
in comic book history for me issue 4 of
Watchmen dr. manhattan's origin story
like his interactions with his father a
very brief I think I have 3 or 4 panels
but when he's sucking the cogs out of
the window and talking about the atom
bomb and what it means for the future
and all that all that is beautiful
and you're right if they just had one or
two glimpses of this you know it's not
that bad writing really the marionette
maker hanging himself like it you know I
don't mind it at all I think it's kind
of clever but you drawn out to this pace
it's just tasteless yeah and it just
plugs along and when you halfway through
the the run I just I don't know what's
happening like we still haven't had
Superman in it yeah after the first
issue we still haven't really had dr.
Manhattan Ilia except for a cameo and
those are the things people want to see
we don't want an issue about the mime
and marionette no I mean this is this is
the kind of stuff that would go in
before Doomsday Clock
yeah they ever did that graphic novel
and they were like oh yeah looking
forward to review and that but if they
did do that graphic novel Tom which
they're probably will because I've
mentioned it now like when he has [ __ ]
and this is the kind of thing you would
find in that not in the main plot not
something you
Haribo you know I mean the Minutemen you
don't really need an origin story for
them you just need that key event where
the comedian tried to rape Sally Jupiter
and that's it that's all you really need
this it's not needed it's just dull and
you're completely right what you said
earlier like we get to see the inciting
incident of them leaving them becoming
killers but we don't really get to see
them becoming my memory now we sort of
get two panels or three panels of you
know them homeless by dumpster him being
a mime and you know distracting and she
steals food and that sort of idea which
again it's kind of nice it's kind of
more ask it tells a lot by using very
little we see them sort of defending
themselves I guess one of the guys has a
topknot similar to the fogs in Watchmen
all the guys who see pale horse but
that's a bit of a reach that that
probably was you know incidental yeah
and then stuff about you know well that
they're [ __ ] as comedian is pursuing
them then having the child what was the
deal about the child again so dr.
Manhattan spared them or something I
can't really remember he said he knew
the location of the child I think yam
and had a photo of it and showed her it
and said look love if you want to see
this kid you better come with me on this
terrible graphic novel lock yeah and she
was oh right I'll be there yeah and
comedian confronts them in bed and gets
shocked by Joker Joker Don's the smiley
face which is kind of nice it's kind of
something he would probably appropriate
but yet again as I was going through
this issue and I was saying to my
girlfriend oh my god nothing's going on
nothing's going on I was thinking the
final panel was just gonna be a paradigm
shift but it's not it's not it's just
[ __ ]
oh there's Batman there behind the Joker
so the Joker still got them oh yeah yeah
so Batman's fell asleep in his own
graphic novel is that bored
um yeah it's just
it's three reason it what you think I do
like the Koala at the end which is to
truly laugh you must be able to take
your pain and play with it like Charlie
Chaplin and it sums up Watchmen you know
that it's a nice quote but someone else
has done it does that make the boot good
no Doomsday Clock its quoting something
else that's really good but does that
make it good in itself
no so I'm sick of it Tom uh yeah I what
you mean we're only halfway through I
can't believe it I really can't believe
it and I haven't really enjoyed it I
guess I could I mean it's been a bit of
a blur for me and I was trying to sort
of remember before I got into this issue
and I couldn't struggling to you know
some of the Reggie stuff I think in the
asylum was alright and the Sun it's here
and there but but yeah is um it's drab
and I know you don't really read the
back man I haven't really either one of
the things that I like is that we get an
insight into the other metahumans and
these worlds and I I love people coming
up with super ideas one of the ones that
caught my eye was the sleeping soldiers
from Australia and there's one called
humble uru which I'm a bit of a word
nerd to a certain extent I like word
beginnings so I know Amba means dream or
Umbra means dream and uluru is actually
the aboriginal name for Australia so
it's that's quite clever they's on Balu
I think that's quite nice dark Ranger
and miss midnight aren't quite as clever
again are we gonna see these heroes or
you know I hope so but we already got
sick we only got what six you left we
even meet them so yeah it really needs
to pick its feet up to be honest and
just get on with it because it's
dragging so much right now just
ridiculous like and when it's bimonthly
as well yeah feels like it's going on
forever and going nowhere and I've just
I've just completely
I've lost disinterest Liam I lost
disinterest yeah I mean it's good I've
lost interest in it Tom I understand I
understand our unfortunately you know we
have to keep going we have to keep
moving on after depressing and we will
be back
foredoomed let me see if actually cuz I
remember last time we spoke we could see
the covers so I wonder what the cover of
the next one is I know it sort of T's at
the end with Rorschach but but yeah it's
it's not bright but let us know down
below in the comments emails email us as
well watching The Watchmen pod at gmail
comm we'll get to the emails of the next
issue and I believe the next thing we're
doing we're actually wrapping up
Watchmen right yeah one last issue of a
crazy hope everyone's excited for it and
I know I'm not so so yeah wrapping it up
and then with doing the movie yes and
then before Watchmen we need to do four
and then possibly the TV show yeah but
we don't know we don't know maybe in the
future we will I've just just actually
because I forgot about our email just
run into her email and we've got a
fantastically long email about issues
eleven and twelve from our dearest
friend Eric Ferguson Eric if you're
listening we will obviously get to that
when we talk about Watchmen in toy Lee's
even include the images as well one leg
whales but yeah look we like doing the
Doomsday Clock issues but obviously what
we're here for really is the Watchmen
and it was just boy it was just by luck
really that we started doing the
watchman stuff and around the same time
Doomsday Clock died but it's been fun
going back and you know please
cheers and sound bit know we've read it
and I'm aware of it but it's yeah I mean
yeah it's it's it's not very good people
we all know this and if you're one of
those people who want comic book roundup
he's giving this nine point five and
saying it's phenomenal then you've been
bought out like you know UK you honestly
a fan of the graphic medium you enjoy
this stuff it's turds a turd it's not
very good it's Incredibles to well
people enjoy what they want to enjoy I
suppose I like Batman V Superman Tom so
you know people have different tastes
but personally yeah no not for you no no
no no but I say let us know what you
watch one part I do you want accomplish
yeah I'd really like actually if someone
would write in and defend the book
giannis that would be great
like are we missing something where we
are quite hating on it quite profoundly
so it would be great to hear someone who
really likes it and what they like about
it so if you're if you do like it
shall we try and get a good review Tom
oh I'll try anything I'll try and get a
good review Doomsday Clock five and
we'll quickly read out because this has
been Asher ever sowed hasn't it this has
been a shorter but like we were saying
before we didn't make many others
there's not that much here like with
we've watched when we know you know our
long like I found one on it's a it's got
100 percent rating by make milena
I know Doomsday Clock five so after
nearly a month and a half the latest
installment of the highly anticipated
Watchmen sequel is finally here the
predecessor to Tuesday clock five gave
readers plenty of twists but to ponder
ah I'm not gonna read the whole thing
out Tom and basically I'll get it I'll
get it summary and we'll see what he
says he's talking about other world
doesn't deserve a hero the many hues of
Doomsday Clock
you saying the reality is grim and lost
however its hope making a resurgence
from within it sounds like one of my
ending explained videos so we are almost
through this is a summary we are almost
through halfway through doomsday clocks
run and there are arguably more
questions and answers that's certainly
not a bad thing the series has
maintained its parallels to Watchmen
though it doesn't rely on nostalgia in
its success rather its originality and
flawless execution in merging two
distinct universes have made this issue
and the series unforgettable it's pretty
much the exact opposite of what we've
said isn't it Tom Pohl opposite yeah
it's bizarro world so the scores is
given art five out of five can see that
characterization five out of five mmm
bit disagree with that a bit when
Batman's just leaving people who know
his identity in Arkham Asylum on God and
stuff you know
characterization five out of five plot
five out of five so what what happen
happened last issue can you remember
because I can't was no but it was five
out of five because as good as it gets I
literally can't remember
so Doomsday Clock and
summary is a perfect issue from start to
finish as it flawlessly merges two
distinct universes and figures Melina
what's wrong your stooge what's wrong
with you like yeah it's not it's not
five out of five like even if you like
it it's not five out of five no it's not
it's certainly not but you know we
encourage you we encourage a plurality
I'm telling this guy his opinion yes you
listen to my opinion and agree with it
Melina everyone says you know arts
completely subjective oh I don't know I
think some films and TV is kind of bad
but you can like it for its own reasons
and look you know Who am I to say
whatever
some people think bow wrap is completely
stupid as well maybe they're right
it is completely stupid tompa did you
see it on who is America the other night
oh yeah my um I haven't actually watched
yet my dad takes body I thought it was
Nestle right yeah which is crazy Z good
good friend of yours his knee I've met
him quite a few times I would say he's a
good friend of mine but you know I don't
I always use that term um so yeah check
out who is America the rat pals and then
go listen to Tom's podcast battle rap
resume and have you have you done one
with Nestle before you know I haven't I
really be good to get on the show yeah
yeah yeah exactly after that yeah I
think I did I I think like a top-ten
king of the doc battles where when he
wasn't mentioned on it you know like tag
me in the Fred like what gives man
there's a lot of you like you know but I
bet you'll be crawling up his [ __ ]
ass now that he's been on the biggest TV
show on America on here literally the
biggest show you're right and rap
battles were front and center it's crazy
I found another review Tom we've gotta
get this issue this episode to 45
minutes I'm even mispronunciation I mean
mince mince pronunciation I mean
mispronouncing words just to extend the
show a bit longer so positives of
Doomsday Clock six this is the issue
we've just read this was a great issue
that really explored the relationship
between mime and marionette they're back
story not only let the audience know
more about the mysterious duo but it
also made them care about the two of
them many have said me included that
very frank is an underrated artist he
proves that with every new issue that
comes out such a beautiful depth
personality NDL is found in every frame
I can't imagine anyone else on this book
negatives I don't have any negatives on
this issue each issue I anticipate
something other than what I'm given but
each time is a fantastic backstory
reveal I can't wait for the next issue
the verdict a great issue with a Great
backstory two characters that I think
are instant classics we are now six we
are now halfway point for the series and
it has been nothing short of fantastic
so far I'm really excited for this
series will still bring us now Gary
Frank is in a new era is fair enough was
a good issue though 9 no I wasn't was it
because like you should do you can't do
care about these character I don't and
no mine
he was just led on really we don't
really know about you know he was kind
of whatever infatuated with this girl
and became a killer along with her he
doesn't really have any motives he's
just this kind of mindless [ __ ] like I'm
not indeed look watchman gave us the
most brilliant origin stories will be
ever encountered in comics you know all
of them were fleshed out you might not
agree with their motives but
convincingly they were put there but
here it's just geoff johns putting this
toy in this room but did you not like
that woman who found her dad hanging up
so she became a puppet woman yeah do do
nothing that that's like another thing
like Rorschach's origin story it's told
through like a psychological breakdown
of them in a meeting and just the the
issue with dr. malcolm in the prison
where he infuse him is absolutely
fantastic and you really get a sense of
why's the man that he is
whereas this origin story is just a bit
just a bit along but [ __ ] in it it's a
bit [ __ ] i think that's absurd best in a
[ __ ] [ __ ] shadow Doomsday Clock you
know wheel back I think so it's six more
so it's another year we'll be talking
about this in August 2019
I'll be dead by there no Polycom gaiden
border
from reading this you know thank you to
everyone for listening as well we'll
have to do something else to cleanse our
palates something good in the future
maybe it's just the ticket
it's called before Watchmen tongue
they'd never do anything bad with
Watchmen so I'm excited for it well we
will be back next week as deaf said or
in a few weeks
Bauer resume is there if you into battle
rap also if you like Metallica the fresh
mountain legends I do a podcast called
alphabet' aleca where me and the guests
go for the entire back catalogue of the
band song by song yeah it's often just
me and someone that I just met from
across the world always a really really
fun chat deaf I mean the the channels
been lift off right now right for you
it's crazy I'm nearly at 2 million views
Tom and I'm just enjoying the ride
it's been great and so thank you
everyone for your support I really do
appreciate it and it's it's it's nice to
to just see you works so start a take
off and so yeah thank you
yeah and make sure you watch all my
videos watch all of that advert click
the likes share the adverts click on the
adverts again and comment please slender
man explained 5 hours that's clickbait
no one said that you have quality to
have a lot of views they don't go
hand-in-hand clearly consume say cooks
doing very well I'm basically the
Doomsday Clock of movie discussions we
spent an hour three minutes on dudes
they clog episode issue foil any
remember that like I probably we went
that long but I'm the quorum about
anything that happened didn't it no no
no it's just not there it just had not
lingered at all but yeah it's been Tom
as always watched nor Watchmen pleasure
to do death thanks again bro yeah thank
you Tom it's a good night from me it's a
good night from Queen yes
you